The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I want to remind
you that there's a quiz
one week from today.
Yeah, I know it's soon.
Open book, open notes, no
computing or communication
devices allowed.
Between now and then, probably
tomorrow in fact, or at least
over the weekend, I'll send out
a summary of what I think
we've covered so far
and what you'll be
responsible for in the quiz.
Roughly speaking, it's anything
covered in lectures,
problem sets, or recitations.
I will also post some practice
questions that
you can work on.
And I'll tell you now that we
will not be posting answers to
the practice questions.
Instead, we'll be holding
some quiz reviews.
OK.
I wanted to cover two different
topics today.
The first topic is just
a tiny bit on floating
point numbers in Python.
But in fact, what I'm going to
tell you is true about all
programming languages--
in fact all, computers really.
And then after that we'll spend
most of the lecture on
the topic of debugging.
So let me start with a quick
review of binary numbers.
Because you have to understand
binary numbers to understand
floating point.
So when you first learned about
numbers, you learned
about base 10.
And you learned that a decimal
number is represented by some
combination of the digits 0
through 9, the rightmost place
is the 10 to the 0 place, and
then it's the 10 to the 1
place, the 10 to the
2 place, et cetera.
So for example, the number 302
or the digits 3-0-2 represent
3 times 100, plus 0 times
10, plus 2 times 1.
Duh.
All right, binary numbers are
exactly the same except we
only have two digits
to choose from.
Typically written as 0 and 1 and
everything is represented
by a sequence of those digits.
The rightmost place is 2 to the
0, the next place is 2 to
the 1, 2 to the 3, 2 to
the 4, et cetera.
So for example, if we look at
the binary number 1-0-1, we
see that's equal to 1 times
4, plus 0 times 2, plus
1 times 1, or 5.
So one of the first things we'll
notice is binary numbers
take a lot more digits to
represent them, or take more
digits than decimal numbers.
In fact, if I give you n digits,
n binary digits, how
many different binary numbers
can I represent
with those n digits?
Well, if I gave you n decimal
digits, how many different
numbers can I represent?
How many different values
can I represent?
AUDIENCE: 10 to the n.
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: 10 to the n.
And so, for a binary number it's
going to be 2 to the n.
That's important, because we'll
see as we get to talking
about the complexity of various
algorithms how long
they take to run, or how much
space they use, we'll
frequently be resorting to
arguments of this sort to
understand them.
Now the reason floating point
numbers cause problems for
programmers is that people
have learned to
think in base 10.
Computers do everything in
base 2, and that causes a
cognitive dissonance
sometimes.
Where people are thinking one
thing, and the computer is
doing something slightly
different.
So why do people work
in base 10?
I don't know.
Maybe it's because we have
10 fingers, but we
also have 10 toes.
So why didn't we work
in base 20?
We have one head, I
don't know why.
But we do it, we work
in base 10.
I do know why computers
work in base 2.
And that's because it's easy
to build switches in
electronic hardware.
A switch is some physical
device that has only two
possible positions, on or off.
We can build very efficient
switches in hardware and so
it's easy to represent a number
as a sequence of on and
off bits, which is
either on or off.
Originally they were relays,
then they became transistors,
now they're something altogether
different.
But, what they all had in common
was they were stable in
the off position, they were
stable in the on position, and
they never had to
get in between.
Hence, we represent everything
in computers in binary.
So now let's think about why
that causes some confusion.
And it does only for
fractional numbers.
So for whole numbers binary and
decimal it doesn't matter.
Ints are never confusing, they
sort of do what God told us
integers should do, or whoever
told us integers.
All right, but now let's
look at other things.
So I want to start by looking
at the decimal number 0.125.
What's that as a fraction,
by the way?
Happens to be one what?
AUDIENCE: 1/8.
PROFESSOR: 1/8, we'll see
why that actually
matters in a minute.
So, what does it mean, in
some sense, in decimal?
It's equal to 1 times 10 to the
minus 1 plus 2 times 10 to
the minus 2 plus 5 times
10 to the minus 3.
So it works exactly the same
way that things work on the
other side of, in this case,
the decimal point.
Suppose we want to represent
it in binary.
So instead of a decimal point,
we have a binary point.
What does it look like then?
Well it's equal to what?
1 times--
if it's 1/8, what's
it going to be?
1 times what?
AUDIENCE: 1 times 10
to the minus 3.
PROFESSOR: 10 to the minus 3.
Or, 0.001.
Right?
So, so far, so good.
Not much difference
between the two.
Now let's take a different
decimal number.
What about the decimal 0.1?
I have to tell you that it's a
decimal because it could also
be a binary with just
0's and 1's.
Well, we know how to represent
that in decimal.
How about in binary?
What's the equivalent?
Now that's 1/10, of course.
What does 1/10 look
like in binary?
Any takers?
Well I'll give you a hint.
It's so long, that I don't want
to write it on the board.
In fact, it's worse than
long, it's infinite.
I guess that's kind of long.
It's this repeating
binary fraction.
There is no finite combination
of binary digits that
represent the decimal
fraction 1/10.
There's no way to do it.
And that's why things
get a little hairy.
So we can stop at some finite
number of bits.
And in fact that's what happens
in the internal
representation in Python.
It ends up representing 1/10
as something equivalent to
this decimal fraction.
If I take the number of binary
bits that are inside the
computer, and then I translate
it back to decimal, it turns
out that it's using this
approximation for the decimal
fraction 1/10.
So for example, some of you in
your problem sets -- where you
were computing how much you had
to pay on a credit card --
would get answers that were
eventually off by a penny or
something from what we expected
in some, and that has
to do with the fact that you
were thinking in decimal.
And in fact, you were writing
your program in decimal, yet
internally things were happening
in binary, and when
you thought you were writing
1/10 for example you were
actually getting something like
this inside the computer.
Pretty close to 1/10, but
not exactly 1/10.
Now, when we print it, we get
yet something else because the
print statement uses an internal
function that by
default rounds these things
to 17 digits.
And so you end up getting
something like that, or you
might depending how you do it.
So let's look at an
example here.
So I can do something like
this, and it prints that
because it's doing some
rounding for me.
But if I really look at what's
under there, and look at the
representation, the REPR
function is convenient to get
a sense of what's really going
on inside, it tells me that
well that's a 17-digit
approximation.
And now so that's what's
really lurking there.
So a hint, If you think
something is going funny
because of the way arithmetic
is working, instead of just
using print, you can use print
of REPR to get a better idea
about what's really going on.
All right, now, does
this matter?
Usually it doesn't.
Most of the time it's safe just
to pretend that floating
points work the way you learned
about arithmetic when
you were in third grade, or
probably in kindergarten if
you were educated in
Europe or Asia.
But now let's look at
an example where
you can get in trouble.
So I've got a little
program here.
I initialize x to 0, then I'm
going to go through a loop a
lot of times, where I
increment x by 1/10.
And then I'm going to print x.
And because it's going to do
automatic rounding, it's going
to print 10,000--
or actually, it should
print 100,000, right?
No 10,000, because I'm only
incrementing it by
1/10, excuse me.
But then I'm going to print REPR
of x, and then I'm going
to do a comparison.
Now if floating point arithmetic
worked the way
reals work, we would think that
10.0 times x should equal
the number of iterations.
Because I'm starting at 0, each
time I'm incrementing it
by 1/10, and so if I multiply
the result by 10 at the end, I
should get the same as the
number of iterations.
Does that make sense
to everybody?
That's what you would normally
get if you did this with
pencil and paper.
Of course, it would take you a
really long time to do 100,000
increments.
Let's give it a shot.
And what we'll see is that
if I print it, it
looks OK, it's 1,000.
But if I print REPR of it, I
see it's 10,000, a bunch of
0's, and then 18848.
And, of course, consequently
when I compare it, I get
something that says false.
And that's because if I look
at REPR of 10.0 times x--
well, that's interesting,
what's going on here?
It kind of looks like the
same thing, doesn't it?
But it's not, because way out
there are some other digits
we're not seeing, something
different is happening.
OK, what's the moral of this?
It's not complicated.
It's not, OK write your programs
thinking deeply about
what's going on in those bits
way out there at the end.
It's, don't ever test whether to
floating numbers are equal
to each other.
Instead, do something
like this.
Define a function called
'close', or whatever you want,
that takes two floats
and some epsilon.
And I've given here epsilon
a default value.
And then just return whether the
absolute value of x minus
y is less than epsilon.
So whenever you're comparing
two floating numbers, the
question shouldn't be are they
identical, but are they close
enough for your purposes.
And if you do that, then you
don't get tripped up by this
kind of rounding and
things like that.
Not a complicated story, but
keeping this in mind will get
you out of trouble when you're
doing floating point
arithmetic.
Let's run this, and
see what happens.
And indeed, they're not equal
but they're good enough, close
enough if you will.
OK.
One of the dangers, the reason
this went wrong, is these
little differences can
accumulate if you go through a
lot of iterations.
Sometimes they balance out,
sometimes it rounds up,
sometimes it rounds down,
but not always.
So very simple answer.
Just don't get caught up
in this problem of
floating point numbers.
All right, any questions
about that?
All right, Yes.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't it change
for Python 2.7?
It's only returning 0.1
and not 0.100000.
PROFESSOR: In 2.7?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Don't know, sorry.
But the moral remains
the same.
Whatever is going on, don't test
floating point numbers
for quality because you'll have
a high probability of
getting false, when you
should get true.
OK.
You almost never get true when
you should get false.
I now want to move on
if there are no more
questions to debugging.
I never know when to give this
lecture in the term.
So what I usually do is I wait
until the volume of email, and
complaints, and office hours
builds, and I realized people
are ready to learn more
about debugging.
If I do it too early, people
don't pay any attention
because they don't realize
it's a problem.
And if I do it too late, they
get irritated with me because
they say well why didn't you
tell me this earlier in the
semester when it would've
done me some good.
So, I pick a time.
And right now it looks like the
need has built up enough
that it's worth doing.
There's a very charming urban
legend about how the process
of fixing flaws in software came
to be known as debugging.
It's one of those stories that's
so nice that you just
want it to be true.
So let's look at this story,
because it's fun.
All right, what you see on the
screen now is a photo of a
book now at the Smithsonian
Museum, of the lab book from
the group working on the Mark
II Aiken Relay computer at
Harvard University.
Pardon?
Oh, I see it on my screen, now
you see it on your screen.
Thank you.
So there it is.
It was September 9, 1947, even
before I was born, it
was that long ago.
And so you can see that
they're running their
computer, and they started to do
an arctan computation, and
it's kind of interesting that
they started it at 8 o'clock
in the morning, and
it ran for two
hours, and then it stopped.
Wow, to do an arctan.
Tells you something about how
fast this computer was.
Then it went on.
Then they started the cosine
tape, and started to do a
multiple adder, and then
something bad happened.
It stopped working.
Whoops.
All right, hold on a second.
And they spent a long time
trying to find out why it
stopped working.
And then they found
out the problem.
They found a moth stuck between
one of the relays.
So it had electromechanical
relays for their switches, the
on and off.
And they were debugging, they
didn't call it debugging.
And they found the software
had failed because the
hardware had failed, and the
hardware had failed because a
bug had been stuck in
one of the relays.
They debugged it, as in removed
the moth, and the
program ran to successful
completion.
And as you can see, the comment
was written in this
book, first actual case
of a bug being found.
Hence, we call it debugging.
This was, by the way, Grace
Murray Hopper's lab book.
She is often described as
the first programmer.
It's unclear if that's true.
What is true, she was
the first female
Admiral in the US Navy.
She was a Navy programmer
who eventually rose
to the rank of Admiral.
So it's a charming story
that this is
why we call it debugging.
Turns out it's not
at all true.
That the phrase debugging had
been used for a long time, and
could easily be traced back to
the 1800s when people were
writing books about electronics
and talking about
debugging even in those days.
And in fact, you can go back to
Shakespeare who talks about
a bugbear, meaning something
causing needless exercise,
needless or excessive
fear or anxiety.
Well that's a good description
of a bug.
And he actually called it
a bug when he had Hamlet
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
about to bugs and goblins
in my life.
All right, so I want
to start now--
oh by the way, just for fun,
this is what the Mark II
looked like.
This was the computer the took
an hour or so to do an arctan.
You see it filled--
made it's a little hard
to see in this light--
but you can see it filled
an entire room.
Quite amazing.
And, here's a picture of
Admiral Hopper and some
unidentified mail.
All right, if anyone knows who
this it would be good to know
so I can update my archives.
All right, so now on to some
practical aspects of debugging.
The first thing I want
to do is dispel
some myths about debugging.
There is this myth
that bugs crawl
unbidden into our programs.
That we write perfect programs
and somehow a bug just sneaks
in, and ruins perfection.
That's not true.
In fact, if there's
a bug in your
program, you put it there.
So it would be almost better
not to call it a bug, which
sort of sounds like it's not our
fault, but it's a mistake,
it's a screw up.
So get that through your head.
Similarly bugs do not
breed in programs.
If there are multiple bugs in
your program, it's not because
a couple of them got together
and procreated, it's because
you made a lot of mistakes.
Keep that in mind.
With that in mind, we should
think about what the goal of
debugging--
and it's not to eliminate one
bug quickly, it is to move
towards a bug-free program.
And I say this because they're
not always the same strategy
that you would follow for
these different goals.
And I also carefully say to
move towards a bug-free
program because in truth be told
we are hardly ever sure
that we have no bugs left.
Debugging is a learned skill.
Don't despair.
Nobody does it well
instinctively.
Evolution did not train
us to be debuggers.
So a large part, probably the
largest part in many ways, of
learning to be a
good programmer
is learning to debug.
And what that has to do is
thinking systematically and
efficiently about how to move
towards a bug-free program.
The good news is that it's not
hard to learn, and it is a
largely transferable skill.
The same skills you use to debug
software, can be used to
debug laboratory experiments.
I actually give lectures
sometimes to physicians about
how to debug patients.
How to use debugging techniques
to find out what's
wrong with people when
they're sick.
It's a very good and
useful life skill.
Now for four decades, maybe five
decades, people have been
building tools called
the debuggers.
And you'll find that built into
IDOL there is a debugger
that are designed to help people
find out why their
programs don't work,
and fix them.
Personally, I almost
never use one.
The tools are not
that important.
What's important is
the skill of the
craftsman, in this case.
And in fact, most of the
experienced programmers I know
rely on print statements.
So it's OK to use a debugger but
I think the best debugging
tool is print.
And I have to say I've
been surprised--
that's a mild word here--
at how few print statements
you guys seem to use.
I get these emails, or the staff
gets these emails, kind
of plaintiff, why doesn't
my program work?
And then there's a little
piece of code.
And the answer I send back--
when I reply before one of the
TA's do, and they usually
get there first--
is usually, put in a print
statement here
and see what happens.
And I'm just amazed that when
the code arrives it doesn't
have these statements in it.
My favorite response, was I sent
an email to a student,
who shall go nameless, and he--
or maybe it was a she--
and I said, insert a print
statement here
and see what happens.
And I got back to reply saying,
no I don't need a
print statement here I know
what the value of this
variable is.
Well, you know, my reply was
that if all the values were
what you thought they were,
you wouldn't be sending an
email saying, why doesn't
my program work.
Put the darn print statement
and see what happens.
And then I got a gracious email
back saying, more or
less, oops, I see.
But please, when you send us
some code, you want some help,
send us code with some print
statements already in it to at
least show us that
you've tried to
find the bug yourself.
All right, so what we're
essentially doing when we
insert print statements in a
code is searching for the
place in our program where
things have gone awry.
And the key to being a good
debugger is to be systematic
in this search.
So you saw that when we looked
at algorithms for things like
exhaustive enumeration.
We said, well if we're searching
for an answer, we
have to search the space
carefully one at a time.
And then we said, if we want
to search it efficiently,
maybe instead of starting at the
beginning and just going
to the end, we should use
something like binary search.
The same techniques can
be used when you're
searching for bugs.
So I recommend searching for
bugs using some approximation
to binary search.
And we'll see an example of this
as we go forward, but as
we look at the example what I
want you to think about is
what are we searching for?
We know our program
doesn't work.
So the question that I like to
ask, is not why didn't it
produce the answer
I wanted it to?
But, how could it have done
what it had done?
This is a subtly different
question.
And it's usually a much easier
question to answer.
Not why didn't it do
the right thing,
but here it did something.
So I already know what it did.
And I say, I didn't expect
it to do that, so
why did it do that?
Once I know why it did what it
did, it's usually pretty easy
to think how to fix it.
So that's the first
question I ask.
I then go about it using
something akin to the
scientific method, which
we all learned
about many years ago.
And basically the scientific
method is based upon studying
available data.
The data you have is of course
the program text itself, the
test results, you ran some tests
and got the wrong answer
which is why you knew
you had a bug.
And then you can probe it, you
can change the test results by
using print statements so that
you have more data to study.
Keep in mind that you don't
understand this program,
because if you did
it would work.
Once I study this, I form a
hypothesis that at least I
think is consistent
with the data.
And then I go and design and run
a repeatable experiment.
And I want to emphasize the
word repeatable, here.
And again the key thing as with
the scientific method,
the experiment to be useful
must have the potential to
refute the hypothesis.
Why might repeatability
to be an issue?
Well, as we'll see pretty
soon, a lot of programs
involve randomness.
Where you're doing something
equivalent to flipping a coin,
somewhere in the program which
might come up heads or tails,
and the program would
do different things.
We'll see why that's an
important programming
techniques soon.
And once you do that, you can
get different results with
different runs.
More subtly there can be various
kinds of timing errors
deep down in the operating
system where you have multiple
activities going on
at the same time.
This is usually the reason that
you'll see say, Windows
crash, or Word, or PowerPoint,
or something else.
Because there's some timing
error that occurs sometimes.
And probably most commonly,
because there's human input.
Somebody typed something
and they might
type something different.
So one of the things you want
to do when you're systematic
is make sure that you
can replay things.
And we'll talk more about this
when we get to randomness,
about how we go about
doing that.
All right, now let's try and
put this all together in a
little program.
If you've been studying your
handout, as at least one of
the TA's did, you've been kind
of mystified by the fact that
there's a pretty crummy
looking program in it.
And unlike sometimes when I
make mistakes I don't know
I've made, here I
intentionally made some mistakes.
So let's look at this program.
I wrote a function called
is_palindrome that takes in a
list and is intended to return
true if the list is a
palindrome and false
otherwise.
Then I wrote this little program
called Silly that uses
isPal, takes in a number,
requests that the user make
that many inputs, then calls
isPal to find out whether or
not the resultant list
is a palindrome.
Not too complicated.
But now let's run it.
Do Silly of 'five'.
And it tells me 'abcde'
is a palindrome.
All right, I have a bug.
Now I need to go try
and find that bug.
So the first thing I need to
think about when I'm looking
for it is to try and find a
smaller piece of input that
will produce the bug.
So I want to find small input
on which program fails.
Why do I want to find
a smaller input?
Well, a in this case it's less
typing, b if it's a real
program it's probably less
execution time to make it run,
but c it'll be easier to debug
because there are fewer kinds
of problems.
So let me try it on a
small piece of input
say, Silly of 1.
Oh, it gets that right.
So that's no good.
Let me try something else, let's
try Silly of 2, I'm sort
of sneaking up.
It gets that one wrong.
All right, so I know I can
test it on a small input.
So that's a good thing.
I now have a simple test.
Now in this case the code is so
short, and so stupid, that
you could probably look at it
with your eyes and just find
the bug instantly.
But the point of this exercise
is not to find the bug, but to
kind of show the process.
So now I wanted to go through
this process of binary search
to try and find the bug.
So we'll start with Silly, the
top level program, and I'll
look for something about halfway
through, maybe here.
And try and now answer the
question, that I've got a lot
of code and I'm going to find a
point halfway through it and
try and ask is the bug above
this, or below this.
So I need to find some
intermediate value I can check.
And at this point in the program
the only thing I have
done is accumulate
the input, right?
So there's nothing
else to ask.
So my hypothesis is that
everything is good and that
the input will be 'ab'.
So let's try it.
Let's print result here every
time through and see if we get
what we wanted to get.
All right, that's not
what I expected.
So something is wrong.
What's wrong?
Why is result always
the empty list?
I can out-wait you.
AUDIENCE: Because whenever it
goes through the for loop it
keeps coming back.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So every time through the for
loop, it's reinitializing--
whoa, got you.
For those of you watching on TV,
I just hit a person that
was heads down with
a piece of candy.
Fortunately it was
not a hard candy.
All right, so you're right.
Let's get that out of there.
Put it where it belongs.
Run it again.
OK, are we happy with
that result?
Yeah, because I've done that
before the append, right?
And now just to be sure, we'll
take this print statement out
here and let's put it here.
We're now searching elsewhere.
Well the good news is I now have
the right result for the
value of the variable, but the
wrong result for the program.
It's still telling me
it's a palindrome.
So the moral here is there is
no such thing as the bug.
Never use the definitive
article.
There is a bug.
There's a story that I've heard
related to this, as far
as finding a bug.
You can imagine that you're at
someone's house for dinner,
you're sitting at the dining
room table, you can't see the
kitchen, and suddenly you hear
from the kitchen, [BAM].
What the heck's that?
Your hostess walks out and
says, don't worry I just
killed the cockroach
on the turkey.
Well, your immediate
reaction is the
cockroach on the turkey?
Where there's one, there's
likely to be more.
Every time you found a bug--
the more bugs you find, then
probably the more bugs there
are still left, because
you've shown that you
make a lot of mistakes.
All right, onward we go.
So what do we do next?
Well, we now know at least that
things look OK to this
point, which suggests that the
problem must come below this
in the program.
Well the only thing that's going
on below this is the
call to isPal.
So now we'll say OK, we've now
isolated the bug to isPal.
That's a good thing.
Let's try and ask where things
are going on there.
So we'll take a point halfway
through isPal, and we'll print
some things here.
So let's print--
see what we have here.
But before I do that, I've
gotten really tired of typing
'a' and 'b', so I'm going to
use something called a test
driver, or a test harness.
And I recommend that you do this
kind of thing whenever
you're testing a program.
Write some code that has nothing
to do with the program
itself but makes it easier to
test and debug the program.
The pretentious word for
this is a test harness.
All this is code that
helps testing.
One of the things that you see
in industry is about half the
code that gets written is not
intended to be delivered as
part of the final product, but
is there merely for the
purpose of testing
and debugging.
It's a big deal.
So don't feel bad that you're
writing code that's not part
of the solution to the problem
set that is there only to help
you make your code work.
It seems like it's extra
work, but in fact, it
will save you work.
So let's call it.
We'll call isPal.
And it's going to print
some things that I
think it should do.
In fact, we'll look at what it
does first before we look at
the print statements in isPal.
So for the moment, let me
just comment these out.
And what we see here is it
should print false, and it
prints true.
Well, should it print false
the second time?
No, right.
So it should have printed
true, and it did.
So this is an important
lesson.
Make sure that when you put in
these debugging statements,
you write down as part of the
print statement what you
expect it to print.
So that when you look at your
output you can quickly scan it
and see whether the program
is behaving as
you thought it would.
So now, works once doesn't
work the other time.
So we'll go back and turn on the
print statements up here
and see what we get.
So it's printed temp as
1-2-1 and x as 1-2-1.
So kind of OK that print
and x are the
same, we expected that.
But we thought we reversed it.
We've entered 1-2-1
and it is this.
What's going on?
What's wrong?
Well now what we can do, is
let's see where it went wrong.
We'll put in another print
statement here, see
what value is there.
Well it was 1-2-1 before
reverse, and
it's 1-2-1 after reverse.
How come?
Why isn't reverse
reversing temp?
AUDIENCE: Do you need
parenthesis after reverse?
PROFESSOR: Exactly, I need
parenthesis after reverse.
Whoa, close.
Because without the parentheses,
all reverse is
doing is nothing.
That's just the name of the
method, not an invocation of
the method, right?
All right, now let's run it.
Good news and bad news.
What's the good news?
It has indeed reversed 1-2
right, to make it 2-1 but it's
also reversed x.
So naturally, since it's
reversed x temp and x will be
the same, and I get
the wrong answer.
What's wrong now?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So, I think
you're aliasing.
PROFESSOR: I'm aliasing?
AUDIENCE: And it's reversing--
PROFESSOR: Because now remember
how mutation works,
now temp and x both point
to the same object.
If I reverse the object, it
doesn't matter whether I get
to it through x or I get to
through temp it will still
have been reversed.
So in this case, what I'd need
to do is this, clone it.
And now when I run my
code, it works.
No applause?
All right, a couple more things
about debugging next
Tuesday, and then we'll move on
to some pretty interesting
topics in the next phase
of the course.